質問コーナー
Twitterverです
（(・ω・ﾉﾉ゛☆ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ）
大変お待たせいたしました(土下座）
まず、Twitterからのたくさんのご応募、質問、リクエストありがとうございます（m(_ _)m）
めっちゃ多かった（真顔）
あのなんでこんなに時間がかっかたかという言い訳をさせてオクレ
Twitterの質問とリ✩ク✩エ✩ス✩トの量がとっても多かったです
ありがたいことに
全部見ました
ｍｊｄ
本当に全部見ると
夜に軽く質問探してたら
こう、ぐあっと全部見ると
気づいたらもう朝になってて
ちょっとミスったなと思ってましたね
本当にびっくりするくらい時間がかかったので
今度からはやり方をこう、また変えなきゃなと思っております
本当にたくさんの質問ありがとうございます
では、Twitterの質問コーナー行ってみましょうヾ(*´∀｀*)ﾉ
いやいやこっちがだわ(○｀ε´○)
お前らな
勉強しねーと
だめだぞ！！
いい精神科の病院教えますよ(´・ω・｀)
俺もΣ(ﾟдﾟlll)
おい！
って、バカ！
留年してないよ
今留年しないために頑張ってます
(･д･)ﾁｯ
やめてー（´皿｀；）
前回動画で僕が怒ってからまだ一人も来てません( *｀ω´)
ありがとうございます☆⌒(*＾-゜)v
僕ん家に監視カメラをつけるきっかけになった
男の子から最近なんか手紙が届いてまして
ガチですよ、本当に
もう一回多分来たんでしょうね
手紙が入ってまして(ﾟωﾟ屮)屮
読んでみようと思います
おい！
反省してねーだろ( ｀Д´)ﾉ
そんなことないですよ
いつも見てくれてありがとうござます∑d(≧▽≦*)
あの、今回のツイッターの質問見てると
かなりこういう方が多かったです(´･ω･`)
なんか、どうせ選ばれないしとか
これ使ってねとか
それはね、ちょっと違うと思うね
それは質問したいとかリクエストしたいとかじゃなくて
質問コーナーに使われたいとかリクエストとして使われたいっていう
こうなんか違うんすよね
ぜひね、またこういう機会があったらちゃんとした質問とかリクエストをお待ちしています(*´꒳`*)
ちゃんと見てるよ
あ、やっべ、あ、やっべ
インスタ更新なう、インスタ更新なう
あ、やっべ
テンションあげぽよ天丼丸
え、待って、かなこ？
あんたまじその彼氏やめといたほうがいいよ
うん
うちのたけしは結構ね天と地のギャッピングがあるからね
天と地のギャッピング
まじそれやめといたほうがいいよ
あげぽよー
あ、やっべたけしから電話、もしもしたけし？
マックにいんの？
マックフライ頼んどいて！
か・き・く・け・こ
言えたー〝(゜∀゜)))
なめてんの？(`０Д０´)
ウーーーーーヾ(｡>﹏<｡)ﾉ
まずダンボールをスライスしてそのまま口に運びましょう
げえええええ＿|￣|○､;'.･
やぁだ
やだ
はじめん
お父さんと
離れたくない
えええええん
ええええん
はじめん、別れたくないー
えええん
ええええ
フッ
（息を吸う音）
なんて質問してくれた
ヘッフイーン（くしゃみ）
なんか、体調悪くなった
やだ
だめだ、所沢は俺の家族なんだ(^言^#)
ううっ、ありがとうございます
昔と比較されても僕にはどうすることもできません
昔の動画がいいなって思った人は昔の動画を見ればいいし
今がいいと思う人は今の動画を見てくれればればいいと思っています
変わらないものなんて、ないんだぜ( ｰ`дｰ´)
１８５センチです！
ワッ！！
えっ、あっ、うわーー
おい、みゆき
全裸！？
うわーー
お兄ちゃん、ポティトウ買ってーー
え？
はい、というわけでいかがだったでしょうか質問コーナー？
本当にたくさんの質問とかリクエストいただいて
本当にありがとうございます
一応これで今回は終わりなんですけども
またね、書く場所をちゃんと準備するんで
またそこにね、よかったら書いてくださいね
ちゃんと全部読んでるから
それだけは安心してくださいね
じゃあな（U＾ω＾）